Hello, everybody and welcome to
this evening's online Wiesner
gallery tour.
My name is Shannon
Rose McAuliffe,
and I am the manager of
the student arts programs
here at MIT.
I'm joined by
Sarah Herzl, who is
the coordinator of the
Wiesner student art gallery,
and Nancy Dayanne
Valladares, who
is an interdisciplinary artist
from Tegucigalpa, Honduras.
Nancy earned her BFA from the
School of the Art Institute
of Chicago and is
a 2020 graduate
of MIT'S program in Arts,
Culture, and Technology.
Nancy's project this evening was
supported by ACT, by a Fialkow
fellowship through MIT'S
Transmedia Storytelling
Initiative by the Film
Study Center at Harvard,
and our very own Council
for the Arts at MIT.
After a brief introduction by
Sarah about the exhibition,
Nancy will lead us through the
virtual show via her screen
share.
You're also welcome
to view the exhibition
on the web page which we are
putting into the chat below.
After the tour, please join us
for some question and answer
session with Nancy.
You can feel free to submit your
questions using the chat box,
you can use the
Raise Hand feature,
or likewise, you could
unmute or come on camera
so that we can enjoy some really
lively and engaging discussion
together.
Final order of business.
Please note that this
event is being recorded
and may be made publicly
available on the Wiesner
Gallery website or
elsewhere in the future.
If you do not wish to
appear in this recording,
please take a
moment to make sure
that your video and audio
are muted and turned off
during the event, and if you
have any questions about this,
please contact Sarah
Herzl at Sherzel@MIT.edu
with any questions or concerns.
So before we turn
it over to Nancy,
my dear colleague,
Sarah, has a few words
Thank you, Shannon Rose.
Hi, I'm Sarah Herzl.
I am really excited to
see everyone here today.
It's been a really great
pleasure working with Nancy.
I would like to
extend my thanks also
to Sophie Loloi, her
graphic design collaborator,
and a special thanks to Heidi
Erickson, our graphic designer
for MIT'S Office of the Arts.
It takes a collaboration
such as these
to animate the vision
of artists like Nancy,
and I'm very grateful for
everyone's participation.
"Botanical Ghosts" is
a multipart exploration
of the history buried in
the soil of Tela, Honduras.
Nancy Valla her
website to transport us
to a ghostly place,
where the Earth itself
holds dark secrets of
colonialism and power.
The plants in this place and
the bodies buried under the soil
call to us and especially to
Nancy to tell their story.
Nancy's vision makes
poetry of the link
between human domination
and environmental ruin.
Her deep quality
of perception links
the present to many
layers of the past,
the heart to the
scientific mind,
and human bodies to the biology
of the Earth that holds us.
Nancy makes potent use
of research-based artwork
and illuminates the
importance of emotion
to tell stories, both
historical and scientific.
I'm very pleased to
introduce Nancy Valladares.
Thank you so much, Sarah,
for the introduction,
and to everyone who is here
and made this possible.
My collaborators, I want to
say thank you one more time,
and to the Wiesner Gallery
for all their support and--
yeah, for the opportunity
to once again gather,
even though we're in a moment
where that's not possible.
But I'm really, really
happy to see everyone
and a lot of loved
ones and colleagues
here as well, but yeah.
I feel-- thank you
Shannon Rose [AUDIO OUT]
for the introduction.
And I wanted to just
talk really briefly
about sort of the impetus
behind this project and sort of
like a kind of
more personal lens
as to where a lot of these
ideas kind of came from.
So during my time as a student
at MIT'S program in culture
and technology, I spent most
of my time doing research
in this particular site
called Lancetilla Botanical
Gardens, what used to be a
botanical experimental station
that was founded in 1923 or
24 by United Fruit Company.
And I first stumbled upon the
story of a British botanist
and archaeologist, Dorothy
Popenoe, in that site in 2017,
I believe.
And so I spent a lot
of time connect--
making these historical
threads and connections,
trying to really
understand what was buried
beneath that particular site.
And I felt that that place
function as a monument
to the legacy of American
interventionism in the region.
And it was a nexus
of several forces
that shape Honduran political
ecologies and biospheres
for decades to come.
And so Dorothy Popenoe,
as a character,
you really felt her
presence in the garden.
You do still to these days.
She haunts visitors with
her almost-biblical demise
IN the story of
how she perished,
which was eating a fruit
of the ackee, which
is this fruit that you see
here in the background.
And there was very little
was actually written
about her work in the site, even
though she did a lot of really
great contributions.
And she was a great
scholar, archaeologist,
and botanist in her own
right, but it was sort of
hidden behind the
larger narrative
and her husband Wilson
Popenoe's career as a botanist.
And I wanted to-- first
as an introduction,
I'm going to start
sharing my screen.
And I would like to share an
excerpt of the film as a--
to serve as an introduction.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[EEK SOUND]
[INSECTS CHIRPING]
I still do not know whose
ghost you hope to become.
In your letters to
your sister, you
write about all the things you
did for love and out of love.
I read them and reread them
until the meaning of words
dissolved, and your
handwriting became a cipher
for recovering all the
things we have forgotten.
In my roundabout
pursuit of you, I
found myself haunted
by your words,
by the things that we never
recorded or documented,
but whose absence
we clearly felt.
I asked you once if you thought
that soil contained memories.
You answered, "If
it could remember,
then we would eat all the
lifetimes it had consumed."
In your time at Kew Gardens,
you often talked about freedom.
Your inquisitive mind,
your rebellious streak,
always got you into trouble.
I remember because I often felt
you left me out on purpose,
like the things we
had shared moved
to a quiet moment
in the background,
and only the object of
your current obsession
could ever draw your
attention at any given time.
What things should be on Earth?
What should be allowed to
rest beneath the ground?
What do we preserve?
If the soil remembers, why do
we need to dig, taxonomize,
and catalog.
[END PLAYBACK]
I'm going to pause
the video there.
You can watch the rest
of the short in the site.
It's available there.
I'm just going to sort of give
you guys a little bit more
of the background into
some of this material,
and then go through a
walk-through of the site
so we can kind of
experience it together.
So when I return
to Popenoe house
for the second time in 2018,
I sat near the Popenoe house
and watched a group of bees
perform a beautiful dance
around yellow hibiscus.
Dilapidated and in disrepair,
the wooden building
murmured all the things
rendered banal by history.
I felt the same way that
often accompanies monuments
to violence, settled like
a blanket on my shoulders.
Not too far from Popenoe
house, surrounded by a fence
and dotted with several danger
signs, Lancetilla houses
two specimens of blighia
sapido, also known
as the ackee tree, which
produces a pear-like fruit
that if it's eaten before it
ripens or is improperly cooked,
it induces a severe
hypoglycemia,
or known as Jamaican
vomiting sickness.
And from what we know
and read in several books
and biographical notes,
Dorothy Popenoe died in 19--
in December 1932 after eating
improperly cooked ackee.
I spent quite some time weaving
Dorothy's life and her work
with the transatlantic voyage
of the ackee, whose migration
reveals the ongoing extraction
of human labor and resources
at the service of empire.
This route crossed through the
Middle Passage from West Africa
and made its way to several
islands in the Caribbean,
specifically Jamaica, where
it became a staple food
in the cooking of the region.
Eventually, it made its
way to Lancetilla's part
of experiments and propagation
of tropical species
for United Fruit Company.
And as I was doing
my research, going
through several different
archives and sources,
it was clear to me that
a narrative was forming
from all these missing pieces.
And there are
deliberate silences
and political
occlusions And I was
drawing from collections at
Harvard Peabody Museum, Hunt
Institute for Botanical
Documentation,
at Carnegie Mellon University,
at the Royal Kew gardens,
among others, where
I sought to create
a new speculative archive
called "A Dedicated
Mechanism Of Forgetting,"
which contains
a collection of letters,
documents, and images
that were compiled over
the period of two years
that I was working on
"Botanical Ghosts."
So now I'm going
to sort of go ahead
and give us a very brief tour
of the website experience,
so that you all can
go after the talk
and experience it on your own.
And once again, I wanted to
thank my collaborator and dear
friend, Sophie Loloi, who
worked for a long time
to make this happen.
I would not have been able
to do this without her.
And so the way that the
website is structured
is sort of like a
book, several chapters
kind of comprise this particular
web iteration of the project.
So you're able to sort
of experience the film,
and then also enter the archive,
where a lot of the documents
and images are kind of housed.
And the [AUDIO OUT] still
living and it's ongoing
and more and more
things are being added,
so please check
back often to see.
[INAUDIBLE] like I could kind of
show you what that looks like.
And the archive is
interactive which
means that things can be kind
of reconfigured and rearranged
and they can be coded
in different ways,
and different relationships
have kind of emerged from them.
And these are kind
of sourced from--
some of the artifacts, for
example, that Dorothy Popenoe
unearthed while she was
doing work at Lancetilla.
Some of these are film stills.
Some of these are some sort
of letter, fictional letter
exchanges, letters that
I wrote to Dorothy,
as well as some
of the photographs
that she took while
she was at Lancetilla.
Yeah, for now, the
archive is still growing,
but I'm looking
forward very much
to putting more of the
material that's on there,
and so please go ahead and
play with it and experience it.
It's meant to be experienced
more as a photo album,
or a little bit more intimately
than traditional sort
of archival form, and so, yeah.
I'm going to kind of go back.
The rest of the
website is sort of
comprised of a series of
writings and fictions.
They kind of tell about
sort of Dorothy's experience
at Lancetilla, and I wanted to
sort of read a brief excerpt
from one of the
pieces of writing.
I was buried near the pomeriums.
The Valley of Lancetilla had
been cultivated and engineered
for hundreds of years
before we arrived.
Before it, the people who
lived here had even settled it.
Let me tell you about
the worlds within worlds
that came from Lancetilla
This has always been
a place of death,
where bodies were
fed to the soil,
and then proceed to be
coming and transforming.
In order to ensure the
formation of the acres
upon acres upon plantations
in the coast of Honduras,
we chose to accept the
death of many things.
In the soggy marsh
of the plantation,
everything makes love.
Everything consumes everything.
Then, it returns and releases.
To summon the specters
that are buried
in the marshlands in
the jungle requires
an act of necromancy and magic.
A Specter is that which
leaves behind an imprint,
whose frequency cannot be sensed
with tools for quantification.
Rather, it requires
a sensibility
to speak to the
inanimate and the dead,
and the living things
that are considered dead,
but aren't, and the
persons whose animacy
has been obscured and
undermined by structures
of power and dispossession.
To accommodate for the world
we were about to build,
we burned a billion
graves, leveled,
raised to the ground,
cemeteries within cemeteries
of microbial subjectivities
and vegetal life,
ecological networks
that must now
parlay an imbalance
in the systems that
have been disrupted.
The things that once
slept, now have awakened.
Whose life to witness
choose to mourn?
And whose deaths to do
we then memorialize?
And so you can sort
of experience this
as a sort of web
version of the text.
You can kind of go
through, and it's not
in any particular
chronological order,
but it's rather more of
a collaging of narratives
and temporalities.
And finally, as part of these
sort of fictional exchanges
that I had with Dorothy,
I spent some time
writing letters to her
over a period of two years
and I felt that I sort of like
had an experience with her that
was across time.
And I wanted to read to
you one of the letters
that I wrote to her during
my time doing research.
I'm going to read
it out loud now.
Dear Dorothy, it's strange to
be writing to you right now,
in 2020, to express wonder
at the various interests
and desires we share,
despite being cultivated
under different worlds.
I recently visited
Peabody Museum
which houses the collection of
your photographs and artifacts
that you excavated
from Lancetilla.
I finished my time
as student here
in Cambridge, Massachusetts.
I think of the places
you frequented here
and the institutions that across
time mark both of our lives.
What is the likelihood that I
would find you here as well?
I wanted to share with you
a bit of my family history
and my motivations behind
writing to a ghost.
As a child, mornings
in my house were
marked by rituals of death.
Although no one ever explicitly
told me, they were so.
The cracking open of windows,
the rituals around the cutting
of hair, the portents
of the animals,
and the blooming of
rare flowers that
were marked with a pencil
on the kitchen calendar.
When it rained, we remembered.
A smell of [INAUDIBLE] were
served as both [INAUDIBLE]
and a wound, a reminder of the
circumstances which brought us
to other shores and other seas.
It's hard sometimes to
imagine ourselves as young
as we were living in that house,
the one that is no longer home.
We still remember the
cliffs and the hideouts,
memories of a childhood's
worth of mapping
the proximate and the familiar.
Tiny taxonomies of
rocks shells and leaves.
Here is a favorite tree.
These are the best
branches to pick mangoes,
and that is the
best time to hear
the song of the luminous bird.
We learn from our
grandmothers to read
the paths of the insects
and the white moths
that are [INAUDIBLE]
moss on the guava tree.
We knew that April
rain brings a blanket
of insects that
crawl inside our ear
and the migrant ants whose
yearly visits invited
the winds.
The moth, my grandmother's
favorite prophet,
would often visit
with the same missive
to announce the
coming of an ending.
Our family, cursed with
the gift of long lifespans,
was deeply intimate with
a kind of mourning that
has nothing to do with burials.
Only now do I realize how
so many of our daily rituals
were colored by the
remnants of the nonliving.
It's here at the crossing
of these thresholds
that the world of the
dead folds into my own.
And so you see, dear Dorothy,
at certain times of day
we're not so far
from each other.
Sometimes as if you're--
I feel as if you're sitting ne--
I feel as if you're
sitting next to me.
Until next time.
And this concludes sort
of my little brief tour
of the website and the web
experience of this project.
And I think, yeah, I--
if anyone has any questions
I don't know, Sarah.
What's next, but--
Oh, I will chime back in.
Thank you so much.
That was fantastic
and really compelling
and I'm sure I have questions.
I hope other people do.
So at this point, I would
love to invite people
either to put questions in
the chat, raise your hand,
or if you'd like to unmute,
come on audio or video.
We'd also welcome
your conversation.
Yeah, anyone who wants to
come on video, we welcome you.
Just to help celebrate
Nancy and her exhibition.
Well, I've got a
question [INAUDIBLE]
if other people are
still sort of letting
all of this marinade
in their brains.
There's a lot to take in
because it was so impressive.
So what I would love to
know a little bit more,
what's your personal history
with the research station?
Did you find it And then were
you inspired to tell the story
or were you first
looking to tell the story
and then you
discovered the station
and discovered Dorothy Popenoe?
Do you have a history in Tela?
Tell us some more
of this back story.
I actually kind of
stumbled upon it.
This is sort of--
Lancetilla's a place where
it's become a park, where
you can kind of go visit.
And it's a place where you kind
of go to in the North coast.
I honestly didn't
know much about it
until I went there once with a
cousin of mine and I was very,
very just compelled by a
lot of things in that site.
It was very, very--
left an impression on me.
And the more research that
I did, the deeper kind of--
you go into a story,
I realized actually
there was like a lot of
connections to our history
that I didn't really, really
realize until much later.
For example, my
grandfather he worked on he
was a laborer who worked
on the railroads that
were used to kind
of transport fruit
and materials in
the North coast.
And it's a very common history
actually, Honduran family kind
of history in Honduras
where you probably
had some family member who
works either in plantations
or in sort of like in
some kind of agriculture.
And I think that was
sort of a part of--
also, the imaginary.
You think of Honduran
cultural identity
which sort of like a
fact of strange kind
of shame, but
simultaneous pride,
that Honduras was called
the first Banana Republic
in the sort of pejorative term.
Those used to describe countries
in Central America and Latin
America whose soils
and territories
were used for,
essentially, a kind
of extractive
agricultural paradigm.
And so, it's both personal, but
also like a very not uncommon,
common experience I think
in Honduras and other places
in Central America as well.
That's excellent.
Really good answer.
That leads me to
some other questions.
I see that we've got a
question from [INAUDIBLE]..
Cool.
Thanks.
Hi Nancy.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
I had a question about
Dorothy's politics
as the wife of somebody employed
by the United Fruit Company.
To what extent did she--
was there any criticality
about kind of their position
and his being there?
Or was it more just
focused on her work?
I'm curious about how maybe was
there any tension between them
or perhaps even between him and
sort of his role in the public
or as an official role or
a private difference there.
Yeah, that's a great question.
I think there's a kind
couple of things in there
that I'll try to answer.
So in terms of Dorothy's
politics, I think--
I mean I can only kind of
speculate at this point,
although I did spend some
time with her sort of letters
and her writing.
And I do believe that there
was some tension, of course,
between her sort
of attempt at being
a botanist, an archaeologist,
a scholar in her own right,
particularly at that time
and making and paving
her way despite the
fact that she was often
in the shadow of Wilson.
Wilson Poponoe's
kind of big name.
Personally, my relationship to
her is a very complicated one.
I really deeply believe that
she was complicit in all
of these kind of structures.
She very much performed the
labor of empire, of capitalism,
of these kind of colonial
desires to collect,
to preserve and then to--
like historicizing things,
perhaps, that don't necessarily
need to be historicized.
Or perhaps they do.
I don't know.
So I think it was complicated
because she also had a very--
a way of thinking about life
and about the creatures,
the plants, the
vegetal world that she
was encountering in that place.
I think that she was
thinking about animacy
at a time where it was like
very precocious thinking.
I think but I cannot of course
project these more contemporary
notions of what that
means, particularly under
the post-humanities.
And so I think it's complicated.
I think in many
ways it's excavating
those questions
and those silences
where fiction kind of comes in.
And so I think the
Dorothy Popenoe
that I'm kind of dealing
with here is a fiction.
She is very much a character
that I've appropriated
in a way, and so I feel
my job as an artist,
I think I was here to kind
of harness that in a way
that was productive maybe.
Or I hope was productive.
[AUDIO OUT] answer the question.
Cool.
That's great.
Thank you.
Looks like we've also
got a couple of really
lovely questions in the chat,
so in case some can't see,
I will read the first
one from Samuel.
Artists are often driven by
intuition and motives that
can be difficult to verbalize.
You talked about the impression
that the park had on you.
Can you talk more about that?
What was the
attraction before you
had done all of this
research and processing,
and what do you think
you were seeking
through this undertaking
and this process?
Yeah, thank you Sam,
for that question.
I don't know if--
I think intuition is a good
word, but I think this is--
that particular site was a place
that I felt contained already.
You just walk in
there, you just know
that there's things that
are haunting that place.
It just feels like a place that
has a lot of stories to tell.
I think I had a kind of
emotional experience there as
well because the North coast
of Honduras has become--
I don't know and I can't
give you exactly percentages
or numbers right now
off the top of my head,
but has the ecologies and
the biome of that area
has been largely turned
into one big plantation,
like a palm plantation, sort
of monocultural landscape.
And Lancetilla sort
of is this oasis
that has incredible
biodiversity that's
both engineered,
but native, so it's
sort of like a little protected
area that still contains
the specters of what the
ecosystem was before and then
how it was transformed through
the introduction of all
these new plant species
into the region.
And I think that that
to me was sort of
like maybe the thing that--
the first magnet, and then
it just kind of became
a little wormhole
that I couldn't
escape for like two years
and still trying to escape.
But I think that
in terms of what
I was thinking through
undertaking the process,
I think I was looking
for a story as well.
And I kind of stumbled upon
it and I found it and I--
it's been in my mind for
a long time and so, yeah.
I don't know.
Sometimes you just kind of
stumble upon those things.
These things can be inexplicable
in the best possible way.
So [? Cristiana ?]
says there's gratitude
for the beautiful
presentation and the website
and an appreciation
for the notes you have,
whose life do we choose
to mourn, whose deaths do
we then memorialize?
And the question is
why is the format
of the archive important to you,
or important to this project
specifically?
It seems as though the legacy
of the archive privileges
certain items that
are deemed valuable
with the significant
absence of others,
and your project is very
articulate in the specter
from this place of absence.
So do you wish to take
a position in relation
to the archive
regarding reclaiming it,
criticizing it, et cetera?
Yeah, thank you so
much for that question.
Definitely my hope,
my aspiration,
is to yes, to kind of
look at the archive
as the kind of forum that
definitely needs to be--
or an attempt at being
sort of critically
fabulating it, to use the term.
Yeah.
Sorry, I'm getting
tongue tied here.
I mean I think archives
are these forms that
seek to like frame or to
present a certain version
of a dominant narrative.
And I think that for me,
I was very much interested
in these kind of empty
spaces that you pointed out.
Gaps that can be filled
in through fiction
and speculation.
And I think that that is an
act of reclamation for me.
I think I'm still trying
to work through that.
I don't know that
necessarily it's--
that it's fully fleshed
out or resolved,
but my hope is
that in this space
and by further engaging
with it, I can reach that.
But yeah, I definitely
feel the archive
has been formulated
and reformulated
in so many ways
in art practices.
I was actually talking about
this with Sarah the other day.
I was thinking about also the
relationship to the family
album, the more personal
and intimate archives
that we all sort of built
as ways of experiencing
and memorializing the world.
Also as a kind of
counter-narrative
to this more institutional
and almost hegemonic
form of telling history.
And so Dorothy's
personal album, a lot
of those images that are
kind of pertinent in the film
are drawing from her personal,
more intimate moments
between her family, herself,
portraits of her loved ones.
And I thought that
those kind of served
as a weight that the
things in the archive--
in other archives
did not contain.
And that that collusion between
her more academic and yeah,
more historically heavy work.
I think those two things were
doing something more for me.
We've got another one that
definitely resonates with me.
Can you talk a little bit
more about the ackee fruit,
its role in your
relationship with Dorothy,
and its history in the botanical
project of imperial expansion?
I think you're right.
Yes, that is a network
that needs to be praised,
so I'm going to do
my best to do that.
Yes, the ackee fruit became
also like a really interesting
character for me that
took on a life of its own.
I think that definitely part
of the challenge of this story
and about these
characters, particularly
non-human characters, is
how do you kind of try
to look at history from the
perspective of a fruit that
is very much an anthropocentric
and probably anthropomorphic
desire.
But Ray who asked
the question, Ray,
whose the person who asked the
question, my colleague, you
yourself talk about the role
I guess of empathy or how
can these kind of
anthropomorphic desires--
could they become maybe
tools through which
we can shift this
anthropocentrism, so for me
that was a question.
I don't know if
the form itself was
doing that, but as an
exercise in thinking
was really, really useful.
In terms of my relationship
with Dorothy and the fruit
and this kind of
triangulation that
was happening throughout
history, the fruit
itself was the more
deeper history.
It was going much further
back in time, all the way back
to its roots in West
Africa and the fact
that it had been a staple food
for a really, really long time,
much longer before the
colonial project even started.
And I think I really like
this sort of triangulation,
this historical encounter, maybe
as a vector through which story
can be told and through
which history can
be challenged and reconfigured.
And yeah, I think that the
networks of botanical exchange
that were part of
the colonial project
can tell us a lot about
the histories that
are being hidden now to this
day, particularly histories
of agriculture as they
relate to resource extraction
through the exploitation of
Black folks in Latin America
and all over the Caribbean
and the United States.
Because plantation
histories that
were flourishing at
the time of slavery,
also made their way
through specific vectors
and from the Caribbean and
all throughout Latin America.
And so the technology
of agriculture
that we have now have their
roots, as well, in plantation,
these sort of
plantation ecologies.
And that, to me, is
a really crucial lens
that we had been missing for a
really long time, particularly
in Honduran history.
And so it was kind of locus
and reconfiguration I think--
yeah.
It's I think for me
provided an elasticity
that other more dominant
perspectives of history
did not have.
So then I sort of have
a two fer for you,
so give me a second
because we have
two quite interrelated questions
from [? Samina ?] and Marissa.
So firstly, you talk about
your complicated relationship
with Dorothy.
She is a dear colleague,
but she's also
an agent of colonialism.
Can you say more
about your experience
of getting to know your
home through this character,
and relatedly, the similar
question and thought
from Marissa, is in thinking
about imperial expansion,
it's interesting how you,
Nancy, described your project
as appropriating Dorothy.
you're very deliberate
with your diction,
so can you elaborate on both
of these questions together?
Yeah.
Oh, these are spicy questions.
I'm going to try
and answer that.
Yeah, I think--
Samina's actually my roommate.
She's in the other room
asking the spicy questions.
Thank you so much.
Yeah.
No, I think this complicated
relationship with Dorothy
is also I think maybe a mirror
of my complicated relationship
[INAUDIBLE] to
home, to Honduras.
It's I think it was also a
very personal and deeply maybe
solipsistic exercise
because I was also
working through identity, being
part of the kind of diaspora
of Central American immigrants
in the United States.
And I think that those
complicated relationships
and positions and politics
also manifest themselves
in me as well.
I think that that is
also a recognition that--
the complexity I think of
being also happens to this day,
to me, to other folks who might
be members of the diaspora.
And so maybe I don't know
if it's possible for me
to appropriate Dorothy.
I don't know if that is the
term that I would use, but yeah.
I mean I feel that
stories from the Northern
Triangle, particularly Honduras,
it's really hard to find them.
I think that there's
a lot of them,
but I feel that they are
not given as much leverage
or as much weight
as they should.
In some ways, I think that
the history of that region
has been deeply
submerged because
of American interventionism
in the region
and it continues to
be so, even though we
have an ongoing exodus of--
at this very moment
of climate refugees
that are fleeing the region
due to ecological collapse
through corruption, through a
lot of different reasons, but--
and I'm not saying
that this is--
I'm not trying to make
[AUDIO OUT] reason,
but I'm certain that
these things can
be connected to that, so.
Hi.
Congratulations, Nancy.
Thank you.
Thank you so much [INAUDIBLE].
I have a little
question that has
to do with the archival
impulse in your work as well,
building on someone
else's question earlier.
And the way your platform
sort of generates archives out
of archives.
I was wondering if
you could expand
on how you conceived the
online platform as a space
of cultural speculation.
Because the way I see
it, or the way I read it,
and I've been playing around
with the website since earlier
and it's beautiful.
I sort of see it as
a way to reconcile
the colonial historical
weight of your research
with the and sort of
the semantic reading
of the archive with the properly
situated historical present.
So yeah, I was just
sort of wondering
if you see yourself as--
I've been reading lots
of [INAUDIBLE] today
so thinking of the
artist as archivist
versus the artist
as ethnographer,
and if you sort of see yourself
in this line of thought
and if it's a way
for you to reclaim
these difficult histories.
Sorry, my question is a little--
No, no, no.
It's great.
Thank you so much.
That is a good question.
So in some ways, what I think
I like about this position
is that as an artist, you can
kind of embody different roles
and you're not necessarily
beholden to the forms
or the traditions of these
other disciplines, which
is problematic, but
it's also in some ways
an impulse that I
think a lot of artists
kind of choose to follow.
I think that that
flexibility and that kind
of nebulous gray area between
disciplines is one that I
really--
and that, for me,
was very empowering.
I've always I mean
I've been someone
who's been interested
in history,
but I'm not a historian.
And I may follow kind of some
methodologies of research,
but I'm not necessarily like
producing academic work.
I'm first and foremost an
artist and filmmaker, and so--
Yeah.
I don't know.
It's a gray area.
So question mark.
It just makes me think
of two words that
keep coming to mind that
you've already mentioned
in this Q&A, which is
stretch and reconfigure,
and I feel like I love the
fact that the archive itself
is stretchable and
reconfigurable because it's
like you're literally
parting apart the formerly
known academic facts.
Yes, yes.
--putting in your letter,
your photo, your encounter,
your feeling and
fleshing it out.
But that stretch
and reconfigure,
I just think that's
really powerful.
Yeah.
I'm actually-- maybe
I'm going to use
this as a plug for
the incoming panel
with my colleague, my colleague
Samina and Cherine Hamza.
I don't know if Cherine's here.
But we're actually going
to be talking precisely
about this sort of like about
the experiences of artists
and historians in the
archives, and so we're
going to be having that
discussion sometime in March.
Because I feel that one of
the things that we were kind
of discussing together before
like the talk even happened,
was that there are moments of
affect that happen while you're
looking through all
of this material
that as academics you might
not be able to express or even
speculate on because
automatically
that disqualifies or
[AUDIO OUT] that you're
trying to do as an academic.
And so, the question
is then what
happens to the things that
do kind of produce affect?
What does it mean when
you go into an archive
and you kind of break down?
When you have an emotional
experience being there
and witnessing, seeing
the material spoils,
I think, that colonial
impulse for collection,
for organizing and classifying.
And so I think that that is
where a lot of the friction
is happening.
Yeah.
In conversation
with my colleagues
I realize it's
not something that
just happens to the artist.
It's something
that-- it's simply
there's no space for
that in academia.
Or maybe there should be.
And perhaps maybe there
should be a dedicated way
of addressing these other things
and making space for them.
This-- oh, sorry I don't
want to talk over you.
This is a really
excellent transition
plugging your upcoming event.
So basically I think
we're going to start
to wrap because we'll have
the opportunity for all
of these questions to continue
as the dialogue continues
as more thoughts and
questions come up.
So I think we're going to start
to transition toward closing.
At this point, I want to
thank everybody who's here
for attending this evening.
Thank you to my co-host,
Sarah, and of course,
thank you to Nancy,
thank you to Sophie,
for this fabulous showing
of Botanical Ghosts.
We'd like to encourage everybody
to watch the entire eight
minutes of the
film and to explore
the exhibition at your leisure.
And as we were
just discussing, we
want to invite everybody
back on Tuesday,
March 16 at 6:00 PM for ongoing,
very stimulating and sort
of mind blowing,
conversation between Nancy
and two of her
scholars and colleagues
who also work at the
intersection of art,
biology, and the
history of science.
We'll have Samina, we'll have
[? Cherine, ?] and basically,
you can register for this event.
The event is titled "The Loss
of Green, Imagining Vegetal
Worlds," and you can sign up
for this through the Wiesner
gallery website, which is
going to be linked in the chat
right now.
So also, the Weisner
gallery website
has information on other
upcoming events in the gallery,
including exhibition
opportunities for anybody who
might be interested in that.
So with that, I think
we're going to round off.
Thank you all so
much for being here.
Thank you, thank you, and
have a fantastic evening.
Thank you so much.
Nancy, thank you so much.
Thank you, Sarah.
Thank you, Shannon Rose.
Beautiful to see your work.
Thank you.